[Music]
all right let's talk about something
romantic my favorite yeah
all right [ __ ] by the candlelight
wow candlelight [ __ ]
situation you're a good girlfriend it
brings a tear to my eye you know when he
wants it to be more romantic you just
light a candle
and then get a [ __ ] candles go a long
way yeah what
what is your idea of romantic like oh
like you're you're ideal
right ideal oh yeah i start with pardon
joe because i feel like why why
what the funniest most unromantic option
kind of like [ __ ] well i don't think
i should go first because i need to copy
off someone
yeah i get it you can copy someone's
work yeah yeah
i think there is no ideal romance by
myself because romance is made with two
people so it has to be developed
you never sell romance before you never
let a candle for yourself
and it sucked my own dick what that's
kind of romantic girl
watch out all his girlfriends watching
i think romance has to be custom
tailored between two people
i can't just have this imagination where
i'm like all right we're gonna have a
[ __ ] cliffside
um a luncheon and these people are gonna
come out and play accordion for us
according to accordion he's dating a
[ __ ]
accordions are romantic dating a [ __ ]
circus clown
accordion i would ask them to stop
you never been to mexico where they play
accordion for you can we get the table
side polka please
it's a romantic occasion while you drink
wine you know
keep going i'm just joking
no but i'm saying i'm saying you can't
have an imagination like that
and then um assume that the other person
will receive it
a certain way you have to kind of custom
tailor it to the person you're with
because i think romance also is tied to
memory and moments
that was expressed in the past so then
if you redo it again
then it's like if there's a meaning
behind the action versus like the
traditional scent not traditional but
like
the idea of like the the the the
storybook romance right where it's kind
of stupid and sappy and [ __ ] and you go
[ __ ]
take them out to a date and you do the
traditional thing
that's boring as [ __ ] it's not romantic
because it's cookie cutter spoken like a
guy in film school dude
jesus supposed to be in a jumbotron in
an nba game i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
yeah
really that's the least romantic thing
the [ __ ] do i know about sports why are
we here
that exactly you gotta take her too
[ __ ]
the game uh
yeah okay we asked the wrong question
that's what happened we asked
oh did we we did oh it was our fault
steve we asked the wrong question what
has been the most romantic
thing you've done i'm not romantic why
are you asking me that
it depends on several variables i think
you've done some romantic things
steve i went outside of the room and
he's like i went outside the room farted
once
that's hella romantic that was very
romantic and when any guy does that you
know
he loves that woman i just did [ __ ]
without the intention of getting
anything back from it and then
well i was told that's romantic oh and i
was like cool
okay very romantic very subtle yep
all right so here's the story of the
lovely lady
and cambrie that's romantic yes
just looking at this photo makes me so
tired because you're at a because
they're outdoors
i'm with you girl but but that's just no
in cold weather i hate cold weather oh
you have hot cocoa anywhere else and to
me
but it makes it more enjoyable tricycle
is unromantic
quadsicle oh that's a quad circle glad
you brought up the tricycle and it's not
a quantical either so
zach he runs a youtube channel he's a
youtuber and
he builds stuff on his youtube channel
and
uh about a decade ago his my girlfriend
like then girlfriend they're married now
uh she got into an accident oh no
paralyzed from the waist
down oh damn i [ __ ] up
[Music]
and uh so for him he's like i want to go
do stuff with my wife romantic
but we can't and i guess they used to
like to go hiking and whatnot and
she can't do that tie to memory bam he
took
yes and you're absolutely right about
that this is something that is like a
love language
for for the two of them together and so
what he decided to do was design
an off-roading knot wheelchair
and that can go on these hikes i'm sorry
i took it back it's not a lame
contraption
gina is still exhausted by the way
looking at this picture
right now this is awful and i just want
to put it out there that
romance isn't the same that's cool true
true but yeah so these things they look
pretty cool to me so it's like uh
it's like a it's an off-roading
quadsicle
yeah yeah it's pretty much so cool
dating someone who can build things
i know i thought you're gonna say it's
so cool dating someone that can't run
away
oh that's cool i like that because if
geo didn't have legs yep
i would purposely push her to the edge
of the cliff and go
oh is that hi mom someone called me
you can bust your kneecap she can't move
anywhere it'll be so funny to see your
freak out and then i'll come of course
i'll come save you
nice well these are weird romantic
romantic i like
i like that in his scenario my arms
don't work and i just
can't hold on i'm gonna put the wheel
locks in the back oh
wheels the back two wheels another part
like this i haven't seen
my way of doing that my way of doing
that is like cooking so much and feeding
them so they're so fat that they can't
run away
oh yeah but you don't want that that
takes a long time i don't know you
cooked
you want your your significant other to
get bigger in time i don't know okay no
i would dump them back up and i'm scared
imagine no i'm just kidding hey we got
preferences i think it's okay to say
your preferences
for sure yeah i'm kidding
calm down please i'll be like they can't
let's go to the mountains
and make snow cones with the snow
there's a video
yes this is it is it electric
yes battery powered wait
they got other homies that are legless
all right
so when he made this it was such a big
hit on his
youtube channel that he decided to turn
it into an
now you want actual best producer for
anyone that wants to enjoy the great
outdoors honestly i
i want to ride i want to ride it yeah
wow
that's cool so it's like if you want to
go hiking but you don't want to hike you
can get one of these things
exactly that's pretty good this is how i
would go hiking
do your legs work i think i take it all
back it's pretty cool
i want to ride that it looks fun it
looks really flawless
yeah and it looks like you can race each
other just like oh i can't believe that
didn't exist already
yeah right well i can't believe it
you're not wrong for a better price
to think that it didn't exist but there
is something
that was supposed to have kind of
attended this market and it looks like
this yeah that's when i see this i think
walmart yeah more like more like obese
america
yeah yeah but i mean i can see it though
it's like the fat tire so
it did you know it's all terrain there's
another one that looks pretty [ __ ]
awesome and it's got like
tank uh what do you call it i've seen
those two yeah
oh the belt drive things right like a
robot it's like i've seen like ones
where it's like three rows three axes
yeah yeah so they can kind of roll over
anything
i think it's hella expensive so like the
average person can't
afford it yeah right like with it with a
i don't know it's just crazy money
how much is that other thing it's like
20 grand
i mean the one that he's trying to sell
so he's that was one of the problems he
was trying to figure out is how can i
make this thing
cheap enough for people to actually
afford and he's figured out certain
materials they don't really go into
specifics on what the materials are
but he's been been able to sell it for
four thousand dollars
750 4750 that's not much
and for an additional battery 700 wow
that's not bad at all
is there a payment plan i mean
i'm just saying it's not much if like i
four grand
yeah if i'm paralyzed yeah well like and
it's giving me
mobility uh a mode what do you call a
motor scooter
or um he calls it a wheelchairs are like
three two three grand
i think he's calling it he's calling it
a not a wheelchair
that's tight that's that's the product
four grand yeah
you see me hiking i mean like a mountain
bike is already super expensive mountain
bike is around four grand
oh true yeah i used to sell those
wheelchairs though and um
no yeah yeah that was my dad's business
okay and so i used to
um sell those guys and they're they're a
couple grand but that's so
i think that's actually pricey pricey
yeah so it's like higher end yeah oh
interesting well i think he has but you
get way more use out of it you can't
you go faster in all countries clearance
too of this thing it's like it's built
higher
so it's like you can go over rocks and
like it won't like scrape the box kind
of like pop the wheelie onto a rock
yeah yeah exactly exactly and uh and
then he does say
um using this thing does still require a
fair degree of
upper body strength and hand strength to
maneuver so
steer maybe man that's so cool and i i
don't think it's like
power you know uh power steering or
whatever so it's like there's still
like a lot of strength involved uh to
work on me or whatever the other one is
what's cool is that it gives access
to people who you know in the past
couldn't really go outdoors and like
enjoy the same stuff and like keep up
with their friends and now
now if i had a friend like that they'll
probably just completely smoke me
like if i if i don't have a why can't
you keep up yeah because like i'll be on
a
bicycle and then you know but now we can
like probably go together and stuff yeah
i think that's why
the four grand to me i'm like that's
justified i'm getting my
god if that thing reclines so you can
lay down too that'd be sick oh my god
what's the point of going outside then
you lay down whatever did you want like
a shade like it's covered
while it has jets and it massages your
oh [ __ ] have you ever driven through the
rockies
[Music]
steve do i look like i've ever driven
through but driven through like
yeah like that wasn't a destination
outside
she only flies why have you ever taken a
road trip in your life
uh to the airport i think the longest is
like driving six hours san francisco but
that's about it
yeah gotcha is this lady even
appreciative that this man gave her her
life back and awesome
you want to hear something else that's
super romantic you want to hear
something else that's so uh
also really romantic when he proposed he
took
her first wheelchair and crushed it into
a [ __ ] ring oh [ __ ] she posed it with
wheelchair material nah [ __ ] that you
better get me [ __ ] platinum
why the [ __ ] would i want my old
wheelchair after that
that's cute she had no wheelchair to use
oh i'm assuming you found another
wheelchair
like honey you can't move but will you
marry me girl
i got you first off you can't go nowhere
yeah
unless i carry you so you're dependent
on me
that guy is going to make this out of
your old wheelchair that i [ __ ] up
he is really romantic that's romantic as
[ __ ] she's like oh my god you're going
to be my legs and [ __ ]
because well that's kind of how i secure
you and you don't cheat on me or run
away from me
he's sweet yeah this guy thinks of
things that my brain doesn't work
in that way me neither if this was a
cartoon
i would want to know what would he
invent once she can't use her arms
either
what do you think says she's really like
insane too because like
me when i'm romantic i'm like oh i'm
gonna do this nice thing he's like and
the light blow jobs yeah can i like blow
jobs but for him it's like i will crush
this wheelchair
and make it into a ring that's awesome
who even knows where to go for that
right right where do you go
it's because he's a craftsman yeah and
which part of the wheelchair
which makes me think you know like when
some people cremate their loved ones and
they carry
like a piece of their ashes around yeah
what if you're carrying like part of
their dick ash
that's true you are but then the dick
probably shrinks really really small to
like dust
but i'm carrying grandpa's dick around
now that's true
the whole body it's everything yeah
maybe you could remove the dick before
you cremate them so make sure you don't
get that part
it's grandpa's taint ass yeah so you get
a little pop
oh that sucks to find out you get a you
get a dick coffin
and then you'd have a ceremony for
grandpa's cute
why is that cute imagine the coffin size
all the coffee
yeah are you saying my grandma's a small
dick well everyone's
big dick's running in this family okay
yeah get an extra big dick for your
grandfather
all right big coffee still a coffin i
mean even as a big dick it's still a
mini coffin
yeah dick coffins could be pretty cool
idea yeah i like it